I had a little dog, and it had no name.
I had a pretty pony, and it was lame.
A pig in a wig and a dog in a bog.
How many rhymes each day?
A flag in a bag and a nag with a tag.
How many rhymes did I say?
I had a funny book, and it made me laugh.
I had a brown cow, and she had a calf.
A pig in a wig and a dog in a bog.
How many rhymes each day?
A flag in a bag and a nag with a tag.
How many rhymes did I say?
I had a little kitty, and it lived in the city.
I had a fancy bike, and I gave it to Mike.
A pig in a wig and a dog in a bog.
How many rhymes each day?
A flag in a bag and a nag with a tag.
How many rhymes did I say?
I had a bad dream, and it made me scream.
I had eighty legs and a dozen large eggs.
A pig in a wig and a dog in a bog.
How many rhymes each day?
A flag in a bag and a nag with a tag.
How many rhymes did I say?